wouldn't it be nice if you knew when a
trade was about to turn against you well
maybe you can msci has just put together
a four-prong scorecard that it says can
help you determine when a position is
overcrowded and quite frankly there's a
group of stocks they don't look so good
but before we get to that Mehmet byrock
dar msci head of equity research is here
to explain how this system that he
developed works Mehmet great to have you
on so how do you identify how do i
identify an overcrowded trade thanks for
having me crowding risks indeed a on the
top of the minds of our clients right
now there are at msci we have been
working on identifying credit rates and
with the crowding scorecard we have
nailed it down to four important
measures the first of these measures is
mutual fund trading activity mutual fund
trades at times can be predictors or
leading indicators of crowded trades so
what is this chart showing me so here
what you can see is the early 2009
period when the momentum strategy
experienced that is historical drawdown
what we're seeing is that by looking at
mutual fund trading activity mutual fund
managers were actually sellers of
momentum before the momentum strategies
crash so that's a good thing you want to
follow that's a good thing they give it
a telegraph a little bit what's going to
happen in the future in other words well
you have to kind of dissect it from
their filings public filings right with
the ingram a trading activity but once
you go through that exercise you're able
to identify their trading patterns and
get a leading indicator of what the
future trades are going to go can I just
get a little primer on this because what
is a crowd what is well how do you
describe a crowded trade and why would
an investor not want to be in a crowded
trade well the crowd the trade is
basically large pools of capital
following the same or a similar strategy
it's not necessarily a bad thing and
this is where we've really come up with
the scorecard the most important thing
is really identifying the asset price
implications of this trading activity so
what we with the score card will combine
in the trading information with the
asset prices and valuations to identify
crowded trains hence the use not only a
mutual fund tracking but hedge fund
tracking right that's exactly so I want
to show people exactly on the trading
activity side we have mutual fund trades
together with hedge fund trades very
similar to what we have seen with mutual
fund trading activity with hedge fund
trading activity also before the
momentum strategy crashed in early 2009
hedge fund managers were also sellers of
momentum in fact they started selling
momentum before mutual fund managers so
they were even a more leading indicator
of just pull that chart up again for a
second if you could what is this chart
tell you the chart basically shows you
the short interest so since we don't
have the mutual fund Holdings data to
first and observe their trading activity
we're examining changes in their short
interest patterns and we're looking at
the negative momentum stocks and the
changes in short interest for negative
momentum stocks so when hedge fund
managers are covering their shorts as it
relates to negative momentum stocks that
means that they're getting out of
momentum right right there getting out
of those shorts in order to take
advantage of what they perceive to be
future market moves exactly all right so
are you got the mutual you're sort of
looking into the world of mutual funds
they they give you a clue you're looking
into the world of hedge funds they give
you an even better clue because they're
even earlier what about the third group
well the first two is really not enough
to identify crowded trades if you
actually aggregate all of the trading
activity in the marketplace all the buys
and sells cancel out there's always a
seller for a buyer buyer for a seller so
what we really need to look at is the
price impact or impact on asset prices
and valuations of this trading activity
so there are two measures on that front
that are priced based the first one is
pairwise correlations what is otherwise
correlation it's really the average
correlation among the securities that
are in a strategy as large pools of
capital again flow into a strategy then
what tends to happen is the correlations
of those securities that are in the
energy go up or increase significantly
so by monitoring they become more
correlated right because obviously more
money chases more money and then you end
up really just chasing the money rather
than the investment itself exactly and
you put a bit better than I did and so
by monitoring the trends in pairwise
correlations were able to identify
potentially crowded okay I just finally
the valuation dispersion valuation is is
is the final measure and perhaps the
most important measure so this is really
put a measure that puts it all together
into the valuation space here we're
looking at the valuation spread or the
valuation of the securities that are in
the strategy and we're specifically
focused on leverage here so the
valuation spread between highly levered
firms versus low level firms you can see
the great financial crisis the 2,000
prices where I would save the forest
scorecards this one makes the most sense
to me if we run through all four
scorecards give us an example of a stock
or trade out there that is overcrowded
well if you look at this chart actually
so after after the big spike and follow
it through the most recent period what
you find is that the spreads are
historically low levels between highly
levered firms and more liver firms
highly levered firms have been really
benefiting me an example of an
overcrowded trade that you have
identified with it's really the highly
levered firms in the US equity market
currently but by looking at mutual fund
manager the trading patterns pairwise
correlation valuations we've identified
that highly levered firms against low
levert firms can your neighbor are
overpriced we we don't have the list of
names but but we do we do produce the
analysand email thing between 80 minute
all right sure 70 minutes love msci
thank you so much for joining us thank
you